all right guys something just dropped in
the studio that I think you guys are
going to enjoy especially if you want
something that is going to be a
conversation starter over the top but
damn cool
we've got the Razer Zephyr mask this is
an RGB air purifier n95 mask it was a
concept that came out I think around CS
in 2021 uh everybody was talking about
it and razor actually made the damn
thing they actually made it it's for
sale
and I got it in my hands let's talk
about it foreign
for setting this over I mean I got this
a couple days in advance so I've
actually had some time to use it and
give you my thoughts I'm gonna kind of
do a little bit of a pseudo unboxing so
I've already taken out of the box and
used it but I've kind of put it back
together to give you an idea of what
it's like to unbox this for the first
time okay as you can tell the package is
damn sexy here razor Zephyr on the front
here you got your n95 filters and all
that information here then on the back
it does walk you through about some of
the features of the Mask uh the straps
the lighting all that great stuff it's
Bluetooth as well because it does
connect to your phone I'll show you how
that works on the app as well so let's
get down to it let's unbox this thing
take this off the sleeve you get the
nice black Zephyr box now this is
eco-friendly box they do sit on the back
soy Inc all eco-friendly you know got to
save the planet as much as we can let's
unbox this bad boy inside the box it's
black all black sexy black with a little
bit of green on the strings right there
as you can see from Razer and we'll go
through some of the contents right now
first off
a letter from the co-founder and CEO and
creative director Min yangtan he says
breathe in the future since announcing
project Hazel at CES 2021 to worldwide
hype yes this got news all over the
world we've turned our award-winning
concept into a reality through the use
of smart technology and Innovation
shipped in no small part by your
overwhelming feedback and support
because a lot of people actually wanted
this mask now he goes on to talk a
little bit more about it but yes very
cool put that aside we've got the
instruction manual as well which you
will need for this because ways to sync
it up how to charge it Etc et cetera
I'll walk through some of that as well
for you here now before we get to the
main thing I'm going to show you what
else is in the Box we've got a USB to
USBC cable got little tips here green
accents on that as you got a half a
Razer braided cable which is very nice
with this uh rubber sort of Fastener
here this small details to count then we
move on and inside of this we've
actually got we used to looks like some
extra filters and some pads of sorts but
I don't know exactly where these go to
but I think everything's on the mask
that I need for right now so that you
could use as extras because you're going
to need extras you're gonna need to buy
more filters there are 95 filters which
you can buy by the way through the app
and
then you also have this anti-fog spray
now actually uh from what I understand
this comes sprayed inside the mask
already when you first get it but you
can just sprayed this again if you like
and of course because part of the Mask
is clear where your mouth is at so
instead of having fogging when you're
talking you're not going to get that so
this might be also good for eyeglasses
you know what I mean just in case you
wear an eyeglasses with a mask you don't
want to fog up maybe use this instead a
little bit of tip trick for you there
okay let's put the Box aside
let's open the mask
and here we go this is it this is the
Zephyr mask now we'll go through some of
the features on this and the design now
first and foremost this is a hard
plastic or polycarbonate I don't know
exactly the material but it's very hard
okay this is not flexible but it is
curved in such a way that it does uh you
know fit most people's faces I have a
small head and it fits me fine but this
area right here is really important this
is where it's going to kind of close on
your mouth and your nose area and this
is very comfortable very soft to the
touch so
um yeah you're not gonna have any issues
with this I don't think at all also
these straps you have two straps the top
and a bottom strap now the bottom strap
is not adjustable but the top strap is
adjustable here and you actually have a
drawstring here with a little bit of a
lock that you can use for that these
filters are magnetic it seems
pop that in it's magnetic same with the
other side as well
and then also you have this Grille here
okay so now let's power on these bad
boys okay now the power button is
actually here underneath the right side
of the uh
I don't know what you want to call this
I'm going to call it a grill for just
for this review but yeah it's probably
got a proper name so you can hold on to
it for a couple seconds
lights are up so as you can see you got
this RGB lighting here or chroma
lighting you've got lighting inside the
mouth area which you can change this is
all customizable by the way and the fan
goes from high medium and low out of the
box it was high for me and it's much
more of a cooling feel on your mouth so
that's very nice to have especially in
the warm climate here in Singapore and
yeah that's pretty much it so I guess we
should uh put it on and see how it fits
now by the way these are very
comfortable these uh these rubber uh
cushion or holder things that you put on
the back of your head so it's not just a
string but you're actually getting the
cushion right there so let me put this
on
two-step process folks
so how they say in the manual I'll talk
about this in just a second is you want
the bottom piece to be around the bottom
of your neck and this is going to be
higher up because if you put it too low
it's going to cut into the ears here now
some people depending on your face shape
might like it this way but it's meant to
kind of go a little higher based on what
I saw in the instruction manual and I'll
show that to you and you can just
tighten it lock it and it stays in place
make sure the hair looks good and then
as you can tell right now
I'm lit up and ready to go now I'm
actually going to turn off the light
here in the studio so you actually get
to see how this lights up hold on turn
my computer monitor away and so this
gives you a sense of what it looks like
I don't know if the camera's tracking me
or not on this because it is low light
but yes so you can see my mouth moving
it's like I'm at the dentist you know
what that UV light it's got that vibe to
it and of course you've got these lights
here around these filters that are you
can you can change this all you want
I'll show you how you do that in the app
in just a second
um but overall the initial Impressions
on this when I put it on was that it's
quite comfortable it's it has some
weight to it of course as you can tell
from the plastic and the filtration
system here and the fan it's going to
have a little bit of weight but it's not
uncomfortable especially with the way
they design these strings and the way
that they hold on the back of your head
here it feels really nice actually so I
actually walked to the gym I wore it in
the gym a little bit uh you know earlier
in the day today when I had it on but
overall I mean it was quite comfortable
so
um what I'll do now is I'm going to turn
on the uh the app I'll show you how to
sync it up because it syncs up by
bluetooth you have to download the app
from the Google Play store or the Apple
App Store and then from there you can
customize it okay so now I'm going to go
to the app here and the app is called
Zephyr now it tells me my battery level
is at 60 percent fan speed is high
internal lighting static that means this
light here is called internal lighting
around the mouth I kept it static you
can have it pulsate or do what you want
but I think static's cool because if
you're doing this wave or structural
kind of uh pattern here this could be
static so you know you can change it up
but anyway right now I have it set to
Blue but I'm going to change it to go to
green
that razor green
all right give it a second it's going to
sync up and it's going to change to
Green I can see it there a little bit
there's not much light leak exactly
actually coming from the nose if
anything I'll see lights from these but
when you're Outdoors it's not that
bright so if in bright sunlight people
don't really notice the lights only when
you're in a darker situation uh than a
darker room or in a you know dimly lit
room where you see it
okay now through this you can do
Spectrum
the effects used built in color settings
so you cannot change the colors on that
it kind of gives you like all the colors
of the rainbow through that
then you've got breathing so kind of
this pulsating look
so yeah you got three of them there and
then of course you got static so I'll
leave it at static for this and then now
we're gonna go to
the external lighting and I have it set
to wave currently what you're seeing
right now is wave
pure static
Spectrum
kind of does all the colors but it's a
little bit more you know just graduation
of colors as it goes through
and then here's breathe
so you can choose breathe from B to a
colors on this so you can actually give
a a range of colors for it to do this in
so but uh we'll go back to waves because
I like wave wave came out of the box I
like this this looks cool okay so that's
essentially what you can do with the
mask on that end of it and of course you
can buy filters on this which they did
send me some extra filters for this
review
so there you have it so if you need more
filters you have them here and you can
purchase them through the store and yeah
it says please change filters every
three days based on eight hours use per
day now I don't know if I would wear
this mask for eight hours I'd be very
hard for me to talk to people based on
what you're seeing right here uh and
what you're hearing me sound like I
sound like a stormtrooper coming out of
this but I could definitely see myself
wearing this out for a little bit and
you know I mean you can have a
conversation but it's not the same as
you know talking like this or having a
thinner mask for that situation but
again this isn't a statement piece you
know this is a kind of mask that you may
or may not wear every day it is a little
bit of an investment versus getting a
standard you know surgical mask or a 95
mask for that matter but it does look
really cool
um just for me walking out to the people
walk looking me on the street like wow
that is a mask and they're like oh it
lights up whoa so I get that kind of
reaction from people and you will too as
well I mean depending on where you're at
you're going to get this this is not
something you're going to see out on the
streets every day right it looks it's
like RGB Bane you know what I mean now
in terms of charging on this actually on
the charge you get up to eight hours on
a charge and it takes about three hours
to recharge the mouse from dead to full
that's what it says in the instruction
manual on this so and that charging port
actually is take this off real quick
right here on the side so you're gonna
see that right there that's where the
charging port is and it's actually just
a rubber cap that goes over it and you
can take that off and plug it by USBC or
you can use it in a USBC cable for that
matter turn it off hold it for a few
seconds and actually this is the button
you're gonna hold to pair as well so you
hold this for four seconds down it will
go to Blue it'll flash blue inside the
mouth and that's your pairing uh light
but uh it's pretty much simple it's I
mean you're gonna get this in five
minutes you'll be up and running and
going and you know using this mask and
it's it's a statement piece it really is
I can't believe it actually made the
thing I mean I thought it was just a
concept they were having fun with but as
they said you know people were talking
about there's a lot of hype and you know
razors the kind of company and they're
like hey people are talking let's make
the damn thing and so they actually made
it and it's it's pretty cool so I think
I have my Halloween costume all ready to
go for end of the month I'm kidding of
course but I I will wear this out I
don't know you know if I'm dressed up
more formally I don't know if it'll Rock
I can rock it like that but I think you
know t-shirt and jeans and have some fun
with the friends yeah I'll take it out
and enjoy it so with that those are my
thoughts on the Razer Zephyr let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below is this a mask you're looking to
pick up any questions you may have I
would love to hear from you guys
um where would you wear this mask that's
more importantly I would like to know
from you guys where would you wear this
so let me know in the comment section
below stay safe take care follow us on
Facebook like this video subscribe to
the channel helps us out a lot and I
will chat to you soon bye
foreign
[Music]